another entry in the konami saga now
they're considering making a new metal
gear game despite all the curfuffle with
kojima and the fact that they've managed
to alienate just about everyone I'm Kate
and this is your game spot news update
konami has discussed plans for new entry
in the Metal Gear series that stopped
short of confirming any concrete details
when we start development a large-scale
investment will become necessary a
representative is quoted as saying this
person did not however discuss the
extent of series creator Hideo Kojima's
involvement if at all kajima reportedly
left Konami on October the ninth after
almost three decades at the company
Konami denied reports of his departure
claiming he is still an employee and is
instead on vacation this is the second
time konami has suggested it is planning
a new metal gear game in march 2015 it
said auditions for main staff to lead
the development were underway and asked
interested developers to get in touch
konami will continue to develop and
distribute top quality content in the
Metal Gear series following metal gear
solid 5 the phantom pain it said in a
statement at the time we greatly
anticipate and deeply appreciate your
ongoing support for Metal Gear as the
next step in the series konami has
already resolved to develop a new Metal
Gear title interested parties are
encouraged to contact us via the
recruitment page of the Konami official
website the statements follow the news
at the LA studio behind metal gear solid
5 the phantom pains online mode has been
closed by the Japanese company kijima
meanwhile is believed to be under a
non-compete clause it expires in
December which means he will not be able
to sign new partnerships or announce new
projects until after this period so what
do you think's going on now would you
still play a metal gear game if Kojima
wasn't a part of it let us know in the
comments or you can find me on Twitter
at how not to draw I'm Kate and thanks
for watching
you